Carbon capture isn't real. Wait, yes it is! Herein Switzerland, a giant new machine is sucking
carbon directly from the air. Developers say the
plant will capture about 900 tons of CO2 annually,
or the approximate level released from 200 cars.
Or how about the world's largest carbon capture
plant, Orca in Iceland, designed to filter up to
4 000 tons of CO2 a year? Yes these projects do
exist and they do suck CO2 out of the atmosphere,
but carbon capture as advertised still isn't real.
Let me explain. So the Orca each year captures
4 000 tons of CO2, translating to about
11 tons per day, or about half a ton per hour. Capturing
one ton of CO2 costs 2 650 kilowatt hours,
or so they say. So here's the problem: the average
coal power plant spews out about a kilogram of
CO2 per kilowatt hour, meaning to produce those
2650 kilowatt hours necessary to capture one
ton of CO2, the average coal power plant has
to emit 2.65 tons of CO2. So if you run this
carbon capture plant off a coal power plant,
you'll capture one ton, and produce 2.65 tons.
If your fossil power plant is the cleanest type, i.e.
natural gas, and is brand new and efficient, you'll
produce about 1.06 tons, practically breaking even.
Hang on a second, we have this thing called "greenenergy"!
If we run our carbon capture plant off that,
we no longer emit CO2! Problem solved, right?
No. If your energy mix contains any amount of fossil
fuels, your carbon capture plant will be consuming
green energy that could have been used to replace
fossil fuel production. So if the carbon capture
plant eats one megawatt of green energy, now a
fossil fuel plant has to increase production by
one megawatt to cover the hole. And you obviously
can't increase green energy production at the turn
of a dial. You can't control the wind speed or the
sun's brightness. Okay but what about nuclear?
It's zero emission, and we can increase production at
the turn of a dial! Sure, but we should already be
doing that. If you could turn up a nuclear power
plant to cover the needs of carbon capture plants,
well then why are we bothering with the carbon
capture plant to begin with? Let's just turn up the
nuclear plant by default to replace fossil fuel
production, thereby reducing CO2 emissions.
Okay, then what about a power grid that isn't connected
to any other power grids, and that operates on
100% renewable energy. Like Iceland! Where the Orca
plant is, not coincidentally. If we plug a
carbon capture plant into that grid, that's absolutely a
net decrease in CO2. Right? No. If Iceland
DOESN'T have enough green Surplus to operate Orca, you'll
have to build a solar farm, let's say, to supplyit.
But then why not build the solar farm in other
countries, to reduce their fossil fuel consumption,
thus their CO2 emission? And if Iceland DOES have
enough green surplus to operate Orca, why not just
move stuff like server parks or data centers
to Iceland from other countries, to run them off
the green surplus, thereby reducing fossil fuel
consumption? And my god, we haven't even talkedabout
things like emissions from transportation!
At full capacity the Orca plant eliminates the
annual emissions of 870 cars. Do you know what
else can eliminate the annual emissions of 870cars?
A couple of new bus lanes and bike paths! And
you don't even need megawatts of electricity to
operate those. So if you're a company interested
in reducing CO2, why not just help fund bus lanes
and bike paths instead? That's because these carbon
capture plants are part of the same techbro grift
that has been going on for years now. I.e. you
don't have to change your lifestyle. You can take
your three kids to three separate [sports] trainings with
your gigantic SUV five times per week instead of
taking public transit. You can keep eating beef
and similar animal products every day instead
of switching to more environmentally friendlyfoods.
Because by the power of the Science God
there's this plant somewhere that sucks the CO2
you produce out of the air through the magic ofscience.
This would be the equivalent of you taking
a crap in the middle of your living room instead
of walking all the way to the toilet, so some
company announces a brand new AI enhanced
$hit-cleaner Roomba to keep your living room tidy.
No, just stop $hitting on the floor! Go to the toilet!
And if you don't have one, build one! And this is why
carbon capture isn't real. And by this I mean the
concept of carbon capture being a good alternative
to other measures. The technology itself is
of course real. It's just pointless as things stand now.
Thank you for watching! If you like my content
don't forget to subscribe, and also there is a
membership option on my channel and you can also
support me on Patreon if you want to support
me making content like this. See you next time!